le rhinocéros une reprise au théâtre de
la madeleine à paris la célèbre pièce de
ionesco alors aux gènes ionesco devait
venir ce matin très gentiment puisqu'il
est légèrement souffrant france proche
là et jean desailly et les le remplacer
pour parler de cette pièce d'ailleurs il
était bien autorisé pour ça d'abord
parce qu'il ait une direction du théâtre
de la madeleine qui montrent la pièce
et puis parce que aussi à vos débuts
quand rhinocéros a été jouée par la
compagnie renaud barrault
vous avez joué mais voulant tourner j'ai
moi même participé à la création de
cette ps en effet car j'ai joué le rôle
de gens ont tourné lorsque nous sommes
partis à l'étranger avec les noces et
ross il faut dire que rhinocéros à
l'époque quand jean louis barrault la
montée dans sa compagnie avait surpris
beaucoup de monde c'est une pièce qui à
l'époque avait eu du succès mais qui
avait été très discutée rappelé
notamment ne s'emballe le thème est très
simple le thème c'est dans l'histoire
c'est dans une petite ville une petite
bourgade symbolique la naissance d'une
maladie d'une grande maladie qui est une
maladie qui nous menace tous et qui en
ce moment fait de grands ravages parmi
nous c'est la rhinocérite c'est à dire
c'est l'abandon de la personnalité
l'abandon de son originalité il forme
une uniformité seilam naas et la menace
que fait peser que font peser tous les
conformismes de quelque ordre que ce
qu'ils soient politiques ou esthétique
ou n'importe quoi c'est l'abandon de la
personnalité et c'est une défaite de
l'homme indiscutablement alors il ya
dans la pièce un personnage qui lui a
décidé de se défendre et il est
terrifiée parce qu'il ne veut pas
ressembler aux autres
les autres se laisse aller et lui ne
veut pas et il se défendra jusqu'au bout
et il s'apercevra même à la fin qu'il
était il s'y prendra pour un monstre
parce qu'il s'apercevra ghetto seul truc
comme ça vous tente et des rhinocéros et
souhaitait pas critique de la pièce mais
il faut pas oublier que la pièce est
traité par ionesco avec un humour
corrosif avec énormément de drôlerie est
avec cet humour
un peu surréaliste qui maintenant est
beaucoup plus admis qu'il n'était il ya
20 ans à l'époque mais ionesco est un
homme de surprise parce que quand on a
joué la cantatrice chauve en 1950 steria
34 ans et on la joue toujours
je l'aï fait c'est unique dans le sud
les critiques ont hurlé au scandale
sans se rendre compte que vingt ans
après ionesco entrait à l'académie
française
et maintenant le rhinocéros qui a fait
scandale et joué au théâtre de la
madeleine qui était un des temples du
théâtre de boulevard abri à l'époque il
des pépins de temps du théâtre de
boulevard mais je m'empresse de dire que
depuis quatre saisons nous lui avons
offert un certain alors je vais mais je
suis très heureux 2-2 d'accueillir parce
que c'est la première fois depuis quatre
ans joue depuis quatre saisons
nous sommes là que nous accueillons une
troupe ce n'est pas ce n'est pas nous
qui jouons le spectacle c'est nous
accueillons une troupe pour lesquelles
j'ai énormément d'admiration et
sympathique qui est le théâtre en
liberté de shell et dont les éléments
sont tout à fait remarquables il ya
longtemps que je suivais leurs activités
et j'étais très heureux de les
accueillir
gros coup de ce rhinocéros qu'ils
venaient de monter mais alors avant d'en
voir un extrait on va y venir tout de
suite tout nam il ya une grande
différence dans la mise en scène à
l'occasion de sa voiture
bien sûr il ya une différence dans la
mise en scène parce que le théâtre
évoluent les pièces évolué elle même et
les hommes évoluent donc il ya une mise
en scène d'aujourd'hui ne peut pas
ressembler à une mise en scène il ya 20
ans vous avez ces jouets qui écrivait ce
la pièce est une pièce classique elle
est devenue classique rhinocéros et ses
joues avec amusement merveilleux qui
disait une oeuvre classique est une
pièce d'or dont on n'a jamais fini de
rendre la monnaie
bien alors jean desailly si vous voulez
bien nous allons voir un extrait de
rhinocéros d'eugène ionesco reprise au
théâtre de la madeleine à paris je suis
fait de petits calculs et on enlève sipa
peaux de chats mon gars de pape restera
t-il ajouté
voilà ce qu'il faut faire vous vous
habiller correctement vous raser tous
les jours vous mettez une chemise propre
et cher le blanchissage économiser sur
l'alcool
ceci pour l'extérieur chapeau cravate
comme celle-ci costume élégant
chaussures bien cirées il ya plusieurs
solutions possibles et après que faire
les écossais vous avez des dons moi je
les longues et et les en valeur il faut
être dans le coup soyez au courant des
événements culturels et littéraires de
notre époque
une première possibilité 1 ça peut avoir
quatre pattes l'autre de ces votes dans
les femmes et des dons il suffisait de
les mettre en vain de feu de temps libre
que vous avez mettez le donc à profit ne
vous laissez pas aller à l'azeri une des
rues temps j'étais fonctionnaire on
trouve toujours que trouvera l'a pris
sur le temps et repeint un peu tard vous
avez jamais trop tard vous avez huit
heures de travail comme moi comme tout
le monde mais le soir mais le dimanche
mais les trois semaines de vacances en
été cela suffit avec de la méthode alors
les autres solutions avec méthode avec
méthode et ont le devoir est d'être
malade visiter le musée à les entendre
des conférences visé des revues
littéraires cela vous sortira vos
angoisses
cela vous formera l'esprit